alright this what we're gonna do today
we're gonna visualize the reality of the
world we want to be in alright I want
you to find a comfortable spot quiet
alright once you sit down or either lay
down set a timer for five minutes and
close your eyes
uninterrupted start by visualizing the
ideal performance pace did you see in
your mind is it a field are you in an
arena are you in a stadium are you in
your church are you at your school
whatever you visualize that is the
reality that you're setting for yourself
what does it sound like what color are
the walls color the seats the stadium
seats watch your fans slowly fill into
the space listen to their excitement
picture yourself backstage calmly
waiting to perform for your audience
who's excited to see you perform who
came to hear you sing see you dance
watch you perform for them once you set
the scene remain quiet in that moment
until your timer has gone off that's all
it takes
tried a couple times this week you want
to take it a step further and practice
more I provided you resources in your
workbook check it out
you